in this segment we're going to go over a
few theoretical properties of the
estimation error in list min squares
estimation recall that our list min
squares estimator is the conditional
expectation of the unknown random
variable given our observations let us
define the error which is the difference
between the estimator and the random
variable that we're trying to estimate
let us start with some observations what
is the expected value of our estimator
well using the law of iterated
expectations the expectation of a
conditional expectation is the same as
the unconditional expectation and using
this property by moving this theta to
the other side what we obtain is that
the estimation error has an expectation
of 0 so this tells us that the
estimation error on the average is equal
to 0 which is good news
in fact something stronger is true not
just the average the overall average of
the estimation error is 0 but even if
you condition on a particular
measurement still the conditional
expectation of your estimation error is
going to be equal to 0 let us derive
this relation we're looking at the
expected value of theta tilde which is
theta hat minus theta conditional on X
on a value of x now if I tell you the
value of x then the estimator is
completely determined there's no
uncertainty about it so the expectation
of theta hat in this conditional
universe is just theta hat itself and
were left with the second term but the
second term is also theta hat and
therefore we obtain a difference of 0
let us now move to a slightly more
complicated question what is the
covariance between the estimation error
and the estimate we will calculate the
covariance as follows it is the expected
value of the product of the two random
variables that were interested in minus
the product of their expectations now we
already calculated that the expected
value of the estimation error is equal
to zero and therefore this term here
disappears
this term is equal to zero so we now
need to calculate the first term this
may seem difficult but conditioning is
always a great trick so let's do that
let us start by calculating the
conditional expectation of this product
as before in the conditional universe
where we're told the value of x the
value of theta hat is known it is
becoming a constant so it can be pulled
outside the expectation but then we can
apply the fact that we established
earlier that this term is 0 and
therefore we obtain a 0 here now the
expected value of a random variable is
the same as the expected value of the
conditional expectation this is again
the law of iterated expectations since
the conditional expectation is 0 when we
apply the law of iterated expectations
to this quantity we also obtain 0
therefore this term is 0 as well and we
have established what we wanted to show
using this fact now we can figure out
that the following is true we write the
random variable theta as the sum of
theta hat minus theta tilde this comes
simply from this definition here by just
moving theta to the side and theta tilde
to the other side so theta is the
difference of two random variables and
these two random variables have zero
covariance when two random variables
have zero covariance then the variance
of their sum or of their difference is
the sum of the variances and this leads
us to this relation that the variance of
our random variable can be decomposed
into two pieces one of them is the
variance of the estimator and the other
is the variance of the estimation error
this is an interesting fact it can
actually be derived in a different way
as well it is just a manifestation of
the law of total variance YZ but hidden
in some quite different knot
and this concludes our discussion of
theoretical properties of the estimation
error unfortunately we will not have the
opportunity to use them in any
interesting ways on the other hand they
are a foundational piece for the more
general theory of least squares
estimation if you try to develop it in a
more sophisticated and more deep way it
turns out that these properties are
cornerstones of that theory